Hello everyone, and welcome to this introductory class on Twinmotion.
My name is Amer Yassine, I'm an Unreal Engine and Twinmotion instructor, and I will be your host today.
Today we look at Twinmotion. This is in fact part 2 of a 3-part class on Twinmotion.
If you are new to Twinmotion and haven't acquired the basics yet, then you may want to first check out the introductory class entitled
Twinmotion Part 1, The Basics, before attending this one.
In this part 2 class, you learn about additional tools that give you more flexibility, from animation to productivity tools.
You then dig into lighting and see what is on offer, especially with man-made lights to support night scenes.
From there, you learn about media output, and how to set up still images, panoramas and videos to export to this.
You also learn to export self-executable presentations that you can share with your clients and audience.
With that, others can enjoy your work without needing to have Twinmotion installed.
Finally, you learn to work in phases, which is capturing an animation of the phases of construction of your project.
And so, if you're ready, let's dive in.